If you believe that the more money you
have
the more unassailable
>> [music]
>> um your chance of victory is
>> Yes.
>> you should give up because Apple and
Google won. [music]
>> They have the money.
>> Right? They have more money than you.
>> Yes.
>> And so, thank god that more money
doesn't equal more success.
>> Yes.
>> So that any startup has the chance to
succeed, right?
>> Exactly.
>> This is Dalton plus Michael and today
we're going to talk about the startup
problems that money cannot solve. I
can't [snorts] count the number of times
I'll talk to a founder and they'll say,
"Well,
we have a competitor. They just raised a
big round. I'm freaked out. They're
going to have all this money to do dot
dot dot dot dot."
And
I always love these conversations cuz my
starting point is always
"Uh that competitor is scary. What about
the incumbent in your space that's a
public company with a couple thousand
people and infinite money comparatively?
Are you afraid of them? Like didn't we
start this with them [laughter] there?
This idea that we can convert money into
success.
Our industry would be so much more
profitable.
>> [laughter]
>> Well, if it were true.
>> We've talked about this in the videos
before, but basically if you believe
that the more money you have
the more unassailable
um your chance of victory is
>> Yes.
>> you should give up because Apple and
Google won.
>> They have the money.
>> Right? They have more money than you.
>> Yes.
>> And so, thank god that more money
doesn't equal more success.
>> Yes.
>> So that any startup has the chance to
succeed, right?
>> Exactly.
So, we've made the high-level point, but
maybe we should go into some of the
details.
>> some of this because it's often the
case, hey, I'm guilty of this too when I
was a founder, where I'm like, "Man,
once we raise this next round,
we're on easy street. We can just like
throw money at this problem and like now
there's no more problems.
And the exercise I would do um
with office hours with a startup is to
be like, "Oh, let's break it down. Let's
enumerate. What are the problems? What
are the bottlenecks in your business
that you can throw money at that will
that will be solved?"
>> Yes.
>> And so kind of the goal of this video is
let's just let's go line by line
>> it.
>> about problems that more money doesn't
actually help you solve.
>> So Dalton,
when I try to sell customers my product,
they don't want to buy it.
>> [laughter]
>> So the most fundamental problem of
course with any startup is making
something people want.
>> Yes.
>> And sadly, more money in your bank
account does not make people want your
product more.
>> No.
>> But but but oh advertising, marketing,
billboards.
Those might lead some to some top of
funnel.
>> Yes.
>> You can't make someone want something
that they don't want. No amount of money
does that. Like remember all like the
wearable things that people all the like
bad hardware things. Yeah, yeah, no
amount of money made people want
to use those things.
>> I mean I'll go a step further. If you've
got a bad product and you're spending
advertising dollars on it,
you are wasting those dollars. Like I
almost guarantee you are not making more
money than you're spending on that
advertising.
The only company that's winning is
Facebook and that's it.
>> Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> You're deluding yourself too. You're
actually hurting yourself and if you
didn't have the money because you may be
faking yourself that you think people
want your thing.
>> Yeah.
>> Like if you're dumping tons of money
into Facebook ads, you're like, "Oh,
we're growing. Here's our graph." But
then if you plot the graph against your
burn and it's the same graph, what are
we learning exactly? Invest in Facebook.
That's what we're learning.
>> That's what we're learning.
>> [laughter]
>> And your company is going to die. So um
competitor,
now that we have this war chest
Oh god, the number of times I hear,
"Well, we can we can buy we can make
some acquisitions or we can
buy this fancy exact, you know, we can
compete with this competitor better."
>> Again, sadly, um
the way that you win against a
competitor is to be growing faster than
them
and to have a better product. And that
anything that's a distraction from
growing faster than them is probably not
the panacea that you hope.
>> We have lots of companies on both sides
of this particular debate over the years
where they're either the underdog or
it's the company that's raised more.
>> Yes.
>> And, um
yeah, money doesn't really fix that. You
don't just win by fiat when you raise
more than a competitor.
>> You know, it's funny, I was talking
about um, Workday the other day.
Workdays.
Yeah, an older company. It was
interesting cuz this founder was
basically telling me the Workday product
absolutely sucks.
And it's like full on, "It sucks. It's
the worst product out there."
And what was so interesting is I
realized at this moment
that this founder was a startup founder
and had no context for what the
customers of Workday want, what they're
looking for, and in fact almost
everything that this person hated about
Workday was a thing that Workday's
customers liked [laughter] about
Workday.
And, you know, and the things that he
cared about, like nice UI, his customer
the Workday customers did not give a
about. And so
I think what kind of blew my mind when I
was thinking about this was just like
"Oh, wait, you want to spend money to
make something better and you don't even
know what the customer wants to buy."
>> Yep.
>> Like this will not work out. Like your
imagination of what the customer wants
not correct. And so
often times when I think about this
spending money
I mean, how many times do we tell people
don't spend it? Because it's like you
you don't know
how to convert it into value.
>> yourself into a deeper hole. It's
actually going to be harder to course
correct if you spend it on the wrong
things.
>> Yes.
>> Like spending money on the wrong things
and then stop spending it
>> It's so hard.
>> It's like being unaddicted to something,
you know, you're like, wait, you already
>> [laughter]
>> You got used to it. Like, oh no, it's
much harder to get back off of it once
you've been on it.
>> What about execs? That's a common place
to spend more money. My CRO is going to
change the revenue trajectory of my
company.
>> Again, it's certainly possible, but more
money alone does not mean it's going to
work. Um if anything, if you're tempted
to start hiring these people before
you're ready, it's value destructive.
Like hiring executives ahead of where
you need them is notoriously value
destructive. And let me extrapolate this
a little bit cuz you might be like,
well, Dalton, you know, yeah, whatever,
you guys are making points, but hiring
is one, more money means you can hire
more people, right? And I have a nuanced
point to make here.
>> Okay.
>> Certainly
having more money
is good in the recruiting pitch on why
they should work there. If you're like,
hey, we have $10 million in the bank
versus a million,
>> Yeah.
>> I think a job candidate would want to
hear that.
>> Yes.
>> Also, if you're like literally going
broke and you don't have enough money to
hire someone,
>> Problems.
>> it solves that issue. But here's the
very nuanced point.
Is that if it seems like you have a lot
of money, you might be tempted to
recruit candidates who are entirely
mercenary
and all they care about is their cash
comp
and they don't actually care about your
startup and mission.
And so instead of bringing in people
that are really aligned with your
vision, being aligned with what you're
trying to do,
you're just like throwing money at
getting people to work there. Seen a lot
of that not work.
>> The other thing that I see with hiring
is I see hiring by spreadsheet. We have
money, manager says, I need a team of N
people to do things. You add N people to
the headcount spreadsheet, the math
works out.
That's the end of your
oversight.
>> Yeah.
>> And then the manager hires eight shitty
people.
>> Yes.
And and
>> But the machine you're like you put
money in the machine and what pops out
is like not quality.
>> Not quality.
>> Yeah. And but the money spent.
>> The money spent.
>> And so it's interesting cuz it's like
well if you want to spend that money on
hiring like did you care who was hired?
Were you following up? Were you
interviewing them? Were you involved? Oh
you money doesn't do that stuff. The
money can't buy your attention.
>> Yep.
>> And so that's another area where it's
like uh it's it's so painful to see it's
like oh I just need three sales pods. Uh
just spend two million dollars get these
three sales pods up and then enterprise
sales is going to work. It's like
no.
>> [laughter]
>> No.
>> I'm sorry.
>> Let's talk about culture cuz I think
that's one that's a tricky one.
>> with hiring this is actually the way
money can help with hiring is
if it increases the chance you build a
culture that people want to work in it
in a place that people want to be a part
of. And so if the money goes to your
bank account and somehow we could draw a
line to
>> [laughter]
>> working at your company is awesome then
okay thumbs up that makes sense. Like I
don't know maybe um
having a nice office or something. Okay
yeah that's that's check. Like you got
it.
>> But go ahead talk talk about the culture
bit.
>> Yeah.
One of the things that I see a lot is
that you can spend a lot of money on
your office and on your perks and so on
and so forth and still have a culture
where the average employee doesn't care
whether you win or lose.
On the flip side you could be running
this company out of a
class C
basement
and have a culture where every employee
comes in every day and wants to kill it.
>> Yep.
>> And so, certainly it helps to pay people
a livable wage.
>> Yep.
>> Right? Certainly it helps to give people
health care and so and so forth, but I
wish that there were ways kind of above
the basics that you could actually get a
multiplier effect by spending more
money. And unfortunately,
I haven't seen it. And I think the other
thing when it comes to hiring is that
you might be able to delude yourself in
how good your product is.
Your employees, they're a little bit
less biased.
>> Yep.
>> And so, even if they come in super hyped
and super excited,
you know, 3 months in, when they're
interacting with customers, when they're
looking at the product, when they have
more intimate knowledge,
they know.
>> Yep.
>> They know. And money doesn't Oh, well,
I'm really well paid, so I'm just going
to lie to myself and tell myself this
product's good.
It doesn't work that well. What about
focus?
>> So,
focus is
really important. Um, when you're at the
earliest stages,
you're forced to focus.
>> Yes.
>> [laughter]
>> And everything we taught people at at YC
was focus, focus, focus. And it and it
works. And you would see people fall off
of that once they got a bunch of money
>> Yes.
>> because it suddenly became possible to
do multiple things at once,
>> Yes.
>> to hedge, and to hire enough people
to like
Yeah, just do a bunch of stuff. And
counterintuitively, this tends to not
work. And it tends to be
counterproductive
>> Yes.
>> to to lose your focus.
>> It is so painful to watch a founder
hedge
because like you will
inevitably in an off-hour, they'll be
like those There's always one thing
they're in the most excited by.
And inevitably in a company that's
hedging, they're putting like less than
20% of their effort on the thing
that they're objectively the most
excited by. And you talk to them about
why, and it's either like, "Oh, well, we
have these other things that we can't
stop working on." Like,
"Why not?" Like, is some boss telling
you?
Or it's
it's safety. I don't feel safe
not working on three things at the same
time. Which always confuses me cuz I'm
like, you have a limited number of great
people, you have a limited amount of
attention, you have a limited amount of
time.
Why would you dilute those things?
>> Yeah.
>> Like, what Like, do you Are you safer? I
understand you feel safer. [laughter]
Like, are you safer? I always encourage
people. It's like, I don't mind
experimenting or hedging serially,
right? Like, you learn something and
then you adjust and you iterate.
But, man, it's really hard to be
learning on three different parallel
things. Especially I mean, what's
interesting is that
way later than I would have thought, I
think hedging is hard. Like,
>> Yeah.
>> even companies generating a billion
dollars in revenue, I see situations
where they're
>> riff on this is it's big company-itis.
>> Yes.
>> bring big company-itis, the earlier you
get that way, the worse.
>> Yes.
>> And it's very hard to go back. Like,
once you get a case of big company-itis
in your startup,
>> Yes.
>> it is very hard to ever get it back out.
And so, you want to keep that out as
late as possible.
>> Yes.
>> Yes. Before that starts to seep in,
right?
>> Yes. Yes. And this is one of these weird
ones where I think hedging
is a common thing that screws big
companies. And you're trying to
>> You're copying the exact wrong thing.
>> Yes.
>> You're trying to bring that infection
into your company.
>> [laughter]
>> Like, really, really bad.
>> Why you should someone raise money?
Okay, you guys are enumerating all these
like horror stories. Maybe I should
just, you know, raise a million dollars
and never raise another dollar. Like,
what Maybe that's the right thing.
Why Why isn't that the right call?
>> So, I'll I'll start with the depressing
thing.
There are so few situations I see where
a company is actually doing really well.
And think it's like not talked about
enough. That that that it is
somewhat rare that a company is
significantly helping customers and
doing it in an interesting and kind of
good way. And I think in those
scenarios, there are often a lot of
things that money can help with. Like
one, that incremental hire often times
is extremely helpful.
Two, marketing.
When you're telling someone about a
product that's good and predictably if
they know about it, they'll try it and
they'll start using it and they'll like
it and they'll retain, that's very very
good.
>> Yeah. [laughter] Again, maybe to riff on
that, I think that's exactly right
point. Is I think about this in terms of
payback periods.
>> Yes.
>> Where if you have the machine working
really well,
>> Yes.
>> you're like, oh, our customers pay back
in 10 months.
And it's like, we know this for a fact.
We have so much data. We are, you know,
>> Yes.
>> totally convinced we have a 10-month
payback period,
then you should
raise every dollar
to do that. Like Like pl-
>> [laughter]
>> But I'll I'll even caution on that
because I work with a number of
companies where they would say their
payback period is 10 months because the
person signed up for an annual
subscription.
>> it's there's too many asterisks. I I
hear you.
>> Exactly. Yeah. No aster- Like at 10
months, when you've working with the
customer, the customer loves you,
>> Yeah.
>> can't imagine their life without you and
will pay you
indefinitely,
>> Yeah.
>> then all
incredible.
>> And the other one I would make is just I
think it's an important milestone
if you want to build a big company that
goes public someday.
>> Yes.
>> There are rounds of funding and there
are they're just like core economic
things that if you're sophisticated are
part of doing it. But I would think them
think of them as a trailing indicator
that you're doing awesome and not the
goal itself. Like it's like the good
hearting thing where people are turning
fund raising events into the goal
>> Yes.
>> as opposed to, oh, we're doing amazing.
This is a side effect of doing amazing.
>> Yes.
>> Yes. I'll throw a couple others in. I
think that once you have a machine
working well,
there are forward investments that you
>> Yeah.
>> can actually plan for that can create
significant value for you, right? And I
think that fundraising can help. So,
uh I'll give example. Tell me if this is
too messy, but um you know, Uber comes
out, it is working on black cars.
>> Yep.
>> It invents this space.
And
then Lyft comes out and it is working
with normal people's cars and normal
drivers.
You know, if I'm Uber in that position,
it's kind of like, "Oh, I understand the
space is great. I understand that's a
maybe a better model that I want to
iterate towards. If I want to raise
money to help me get there,
>> Yes.
>> I know a lot like, you know, like I'm
doing this as a very intelligent
investment.
That makes sense."
>> Yep.
>> Um another example is, you know,
DoorDash getting its first uh like 12
markets
profitable and then being like, "All
right, we understand how to set up
stores, how to do promotions, what types
of markets to go to, da da da da." Let's
go do our next 50.
Okay. Like that's the, you know, like
those types of intelligent investments
when you actually have some expertise,
when you have ex-
an aggressive amount of proof that your
customers love the product, awesome.
>> Yeah. And
>> Awesome.
>> To be super direct, what we're saying
is hand-waving, "Oh, we have $10
million. We're going to like hire some
people and we're going to do some
billboards."
That is hand-waving. Versus the examples
you just gave are super
precise and specific.
>> Yes.
>> And I would just
encourage the viewers to to delineate
between those examples.
>> Yes.
Yes.
>> How specific um
are are your uses of capital?
>> I want to throw in a last cautionary
tale here. I think there's two things
that founders don't realize when they
raise capital and they're not in this
position.
One is more often than not they bring on
a board member
who
thought the company was doing better
than it is.
And then they have to interact with that
person quarterly. I cannot tell you how
often I do office hours where like a top
two stressor in a pre-product market fit
CEO's life is the fact that they have an
investor board member
who doesn't like the company.
>> Yes.
>> And like as much as I tell them those
are words, they can't do anything yet
yet yet, it's just like hard to have
like a negative cheerleader
as a significant shareholder in your
company. [laughter]
>> yes.
>> It's like not fun. Like not fun. It is
It's like It's hard to not have a little
bit of a respect, but like
>> I understand.
>> you want to see them as like this
aspirational or something helpful and
they're kind of like, oh, I up
investing in you. That's not fun. And
then the second is how employees'
expectations change when there's a lot
of money at I cannot tell you how many
YC companies I talked to you where the
founder knows the company is not doing
well.
And the employees think because Sequoia
gave them $20 million that they are.
And they start treating the company like
it's Google.
>> Yeah.
>> And like when people think the company
has made it, they actually start
thinking how can I get mine?
>> Yeah.
>> Whereas when they realize the company
hasn't and they believe in the mission
and the team has a good culture,
they think about how to sacrifice for
the company.
And the worst case scenario is you have
a bunch of people in your company who
are trying to get theirs
and your company's not working. Good
luck. Good luck. Money, hell, that's not
a problem that money doesn't solve. It's
a problem money creates.
>> [laughter]
>> Amen. I mean, look, I think my parting
thought is my suggestion is to treat
money as a tool if you're a startup
founder and you have a whole box of
tools. There's lots of tools that you
have.
>> Lots of tools.
>> And there are certain types of problems
that you can use this tool to fix or to
hack. And if you're very good, if you're
good at using this tool, good for you.
Like if you're good at fundraising,
hooray.
But it is not in itself the answer. It
is not the panacea. And if you start
hitting everything with a hammer, right?
If
>> [laughter]
>> If all you have is a hammer, if all you
have is money and you try to fix every
problem with it, it's not going to work.
>> Not going to work. It's so funny cuz
sometimes I think to myself,
you know, startups, the kind of theory
behind startups is that like
ambition, intensity, intelligence, and
scarcity of resources is a better
environment for invention.
And so only startups can like, you know,
big companies like pretend like they can
create that, but it's really hard for
them to do. But startups can create
that.
And
it's interesting when people want so
much money that there's no scarcity.
Yet they still want invention. I just
think if I could bottle up what I've
seen the best companies do
when they're low on cash,
and if I could put that into a pill,
right? Like it's like
>> [laughter]
>> man, the gun to your head when you're
low on cash, that creates so much more
invention
than the
the 6 months after you raise that round
when you're like, now we can spend money
on things.
>> [laughter]
>> It's a gift. It's a gift to be resource
limited when you're when you're early.
>> Great shot.
>> All right, thanks Michael.